[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's
also the co-host of smart money happy
hour and the host of The George camel
show very popular on YouTube both Ramsey
Network Productions and we'll be taking
your calls the phone number is
5225 Brian starts this hour in St Louis
hey Brian welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey thanks for the call sure what's
up uh my wife and I are trying to build
a house um and we're discussing how much
we should have saved ahead of time I
would like to have a 100,000 saved and
she wants to start now we're at about
40,000
saved okay and uh so she isn't as
concerned about the down payment as you
are uh she's just excited to get
going more so than concerned about the
down payment which you are yeah so what
does the payment process look like for
this build when is all the money
due uh well we haven't started anything
yet um and so I would like to save a 100
hopefully get 200 out of our house and
then maybe go 350 total and then just
have 50 left to finish up when we're all
done what do you make which we could
what your house sold in uh about about a
100 okay so you're talking about a
$350,000
build okay and you got 40 how long do it
take you to get to 100 if we want your
way with your goal uh little over a year
so we're not arguing about 60 we're
arguing about a year
right she wants to go now you want to go
in a
year correct okay
um which means that if we go her way you
end up with a $100,000 mortgage not a
$50,000
mortgage yes or $110,000 mortgage to be
precise right am I doing all this
correctly
Brian yes okay how sure are you this
home is going to cost
350 uh not sure that's just the goal
that we'd like to keep it under do you
have a
blueprint no we haven't started anything
do you have a
builder we have nothing just discussions
do you own the
land uh we have family land set
aside okay uh sidebar before sidebar
before we keep going family land set
aside needs means that there needs to be
a plat that is deed to to
you and you have the right to sell it
someday if you all don't want to live
there anymore otherwise don't do this
deal right you don't build your house on
Daddy's land or your house on a lot that
Daddy gave you off his land and he says
you can never sell it neither one of
those those are both deal Killers it
would be purchased okay and you would
own it oh wait a minute what does the
land the land is part of the
350 yeah yes okay and then you would
have full rights emotionally
relationally legally to sell it later if
you want
to yes okay I don't I I've taken that
call a lot in the last 30 years someone
that's stuck in a piece of property
because everybody's going to be mad if
they sell their own
house right don't do that all right now
all right back to the deal so the land
is how
much uh 40,000 and that's included in
the 350 did you say or not includ Ed yes
okay all right we think but we really
have nothing to base this on except
square foot and you think you're going
to build x square feet I I would tell
you this I'm in the middle of building a
house right now um it took us nine
months from the time we decided we
wanted to to get a blueprint a builder
and a
budget okay completed
completed I mean from day one and I've
done it before so I'm guessing
uh that you can start on the process now
and it's probably going to take you
close to a year and you'll have that 100
yeah or not I mean you know it may take
you nine months and then you split the
difference right but I I think you can
go ahead and get started because here's
what's going to happen when you start
drawing this house and you actually
start talking to builders and you
actually start getting bids you're going
to find out your numbers are
wrong right or they change and I doubt
they change
down right you got got to watch the
scope creep thing here yeah my fear is
this thing is double what you thought it
was going to be and now we got to relook
at is this the right next move or do we
just buy a place yeah so I think we got
a you got bigger issues than when when
to start okay you need to go you guys
you can start today on the get looking
at Builders and looking at Blueprints
and getting it dialed in and once all of
that's done if it's not been a year um
and you've got everything dialed in and
you really can still do the numbers that
you come up with the real numbers not
hopeful numbers um then we can say all
right I still don't want to start then
and what I would recommend back to your
original argument is just split the
difference just you know instead of a
year or starting now uh let's say 6
months and by then but it believe me
it's going to be six months at least I
don't think we're starting next week on
this build anyway we got some time we
not build Builders aren't working as
much right now so you probably can find
one that'll give you some attention
that's R that's a good thing slowed down
a little bit very few specs going up uh
if builders that are working are doing
customs and so very few home starts on
specs uh because the Market's really
slow with the high interest rates um
prices have held firm and have gone up
in most cases and depending on the
market but uh the build rate uh new home
starts are down way down way down and
specs have just about disappeared in
most markets wow so which is not a bad
thing it's okay except that the
except there's no freaking inventory but
for for Brian it's a good thing cuz he's
probably going to get some good
attention yeah versus Builder Builder
Builder and Subs are going to be
available going a million miles an hour
you don't want someone rushing through
that home build well and you got 73
other clients instead of just you may be
his prized client right now you know
it's possible now on the financing side
how would you suggest Brian go through
with this because there's different ways
when you're working with a builder to
finance it well if it's 50,000 he
probably can go over at the credit union
just get a loan simple if it's it's
going to be 100 110
150 then he's probably looking at a
formal construction loan and he'll have
to get an appraisal on the plan the
Builder the the general contractor
obviously license will have to be shown
uh to get the appraisal and then that
they'll do that to get and you'll have
to get your approved for your permanent
mortgage and they give you a letter
called a takeout letter which it means
that they will be there to take out the
construction loan at completion the
permanent mortgage will it will convert
over to a conventional all of that with
Churchill Mortgage every bit of that um
if you want to uh but if you've got a
little small loan like a 50,000 out of
400 or 50 out of 350 you know probably
just your credit un they'll just make
you a loan like a personal loan almost
they're not going to put a lot of
regulation on that not going to require
the takeout letter not going to require
an appraisal not going to usually but uh
but if you get up there over 100 then
you're going to have a construction loan
I just rewatched The Big Short over the
weekend of this whole mortgage crisis
man it puts things in perspective yeah
how wild things were back in those days
well there was just so the big Short's
all about all the fraud that happened
yeah yeah and it was just people making
up appraisals and uh we got a whole new
list of appraisal regulations in as a
result of what happened in that movie
yeah whole different
world this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus a 5,000
seller guarantee gives your offer the
best chance of being accepted the home
buyer Edge from Churchill gives you an
advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
George camel Ramsey personality is our
co-host today open phones at
8825 5225 thanks for being with us
America we're here to serve you our joy
comes when we can show you what to do
and then you actually go do it and it
causes you to win bing bing that's how
that works that's um that's what this
has been about for 30 plus years now and
it continues to be Jody Is With Us in
Springfield Illinois hi Jody welcome to
the Ramsey Show hi there hey what's up I
well I'm kind of embarrassed to ask this
question but I am a
50-year-old Widow who has been widowed
for 15
years um I have helped put my children
through
college and I have no
retirement so I am ready to start
retirement and I don't even know where
to begin and how much to put in h
there's nothing embarrassing about any
of that it sounds sounds like you're
make me feel good sounds like you're a
wonderful person we just need to get on
the ball right yes yeah so what do you
make I make about I was just sitting
here figuring this out um I bring home
about
36,000 take home home a year mhm okay so
your income somewhere around in the low
40s uh maybe 45 yeah all right what do
you
do I am a social worker okay all right
and do you have any
debt I do not your house is paid for yes
that's great
news that means most of your income can
go toward
investing so you have zero saved right
now right what do you have in the
well here's what I have I have my
emergency fund of
$1,000 I have my three months I have
three months of my Emer or for my you
know in case something
happens um but that's about all I have
at this point so I'm I'm on the Dave
Ramsey boat I just I'm scared I it's to
a point to where sometimes I cry because
I'm like what am I going to
do you know because don't know because
when my husband passed away you know I
used like life insurance and all that
kind of stuff to pay my house off so
yeah you know we had a roof over our
head and all that kind of stuff because
my kids were seven and 10 when all of
this happened wow well you've had a lot
of Life happen hard I totally understand
had a lot we're not here to beat you up
we want to give you some good next steps
to take and if you're following the baby
steps now that puts you at baby step
four because you have no debt fully
funded emergency fund and really at step
seven because you have a paid for house
and so now the kids are they schools
paid for we got to put our own mask now
uh put our own mask on and that looks
like investing for retirement as
aggressively as possible do you have a
retirement plan through your
employer here's what I have and I I
didn't know what route to go but there's
a
403b okay I don't know much about that
I've kind of looked you know do they
have a match
no okay I would not do that then I would
first do okay I mean I may do some there
but we would first do a Roth
IRA okay just a plain Roth not a
traditional a Roth a Roth so what I want
you to do is go to Ramsey solutions.com
and click on smartvestor and get a
smartvestor pro in your area to sit down
with you and they can help you run some
calculations okay now let me give you an
example you bring home $3,000 a month
you do not have any bills except
survival bills you have no debt no rent
no nothing okay correct if you were to
save
invest
$1,000 a month for 15 years at$ 65
you're going to have right around a half
a million dollars right around
$500,000 really yeah okay what this
means is not that you're rich and it's
really not enough but it's enough to
make sure you're not cold and
hungry right because it will produce
then let's just let's just reverse
engineer this which is very interesting
okay let's pretend It produced 10% a
year on the mutual funds after that and
that you retired and had no retirement
income and I suspect you probably have a
retirement with your government agency
don't you that they furnish
you a
pension uh yeah actually uh my husband I
get a pension off of him but that thing
but do you get a pension from your work
when you retire no huh okay it's just
Social Security I pay into yeah yeah
absolutely which is nothing which is
horrible but that's okay all right so if
you had a half a million at 65 or 67 or
whatever and it was invested at
10% 10% of 500,000 is 50,000 a year
right without touching the nest egg
without touching the goose it will lay
50,000 golden eggs a
year wow and so you'd actually be making
more retirement than you are
now so no kitty so you're going to be
okay that's the point you're not going
to be rich but even if I'm if my numbers
are off a little bit and they might be
one way or another actually they
probably are off in this case because
you probably will not be making 36,000
for the rest of your life you'll
probably be be making more and so you
could invest probably more later
agreed right yeah so the I did that
based on $1,000 in your current income
so so I want you to sit down with a
smart Vester Pro and we don't know how
the scenarios will compare to actual
life but you can run some scenarios like
I just did just to get the idea that I
don't have to
cry know cuz if you'll start now Jody
and you start investing close to $1,000
or more than $1,000 a month you get your
budget tight and you do that you're
going to be
okay matter of fact you're gonna be
better than
okay that makes me that makes me cry
just being happy yeah so I want you to
sit down but it also needs to make you
get on the budget and do it it also mean
means you to get on the phone and get on
with those smartvestor pros and go sit
down with them and learn and let's get
this stuff started not next week not
next year now
now okay right now it yeah and because
every day you put this off it gets
harder if you put it off a year it's
going to take
1,200 yeah don't put it off anymore you
put it off as long as you can the fuse
is burning so I want you scared enough
that I scare you into action but I don't
want you terrified anymore so you're
paralyzed I got it I'm on it I'm doing
it today I love you you're awesome call
us back and let us know how it's going
okay okay thank you guys so much I
appreciate it thank you sweet lady love
that she just needed a little motivation
that she's not doing as as bad as she
thought she was and the time to start is
today what's interesting about what we
do for a living when we talk about
getting out of debt or we talk about
Building Wealth numbers actually give
you a result that gives you hope when
you run math okay you know got $100,000
in debt I'm never going to get out what
it's
33,000 a year for three years I mean
it's 2,600 bucks a month and you make
150,000 shut your winding up you know
all of a sudden the numbers give you Ma
give you hope right the math gives you
hope in her case it's $1,000 a month and
for for the next 15 years and not
missing a month and getting started
immediately and getting good returns and
good mutual funds which probably that
403 be does not have that's why I
directed her away from that you know
let's go first to the Roth IRA with more
control more options lot better options
a lot better mutual fund options out
there now I can be off and if y'all want
to argue with my numbers that's fine
argue with my numbers but here's the
point get with it you know and and you
know I might be if I'm half wrong she's
still going to have 25 $26,000 a month
coming in uh or 25 $26,000 a year coming
in uh versus nothing which your little
plan you critique critic people out
there creates nothing that's what
critics create nothing well the new one
Dave is well a million dollars isn't
enough anymore Dave that means a half
million doll is half of not enough but
it's more than you got if you be broken
crying about it hello yeah we'd love for
you to have multiple Millions but I mean
in this case you could see 500,000 would
still change your life the way she's the
only way she's going to get to over a
million is she's going to raise her
income substantially so she could invest
twice as much cuz 2,000 a month yeah for
15 years at 12% my mutual funds have
averaged 12% for the last 30 years my
personal portfolio and I'm not a genius
the market is average 11.8% in the S&P
so by God shut up and go do it you know
so could you could you end up with a
million dollars in 15 years yeah it's
two grand a month that's it roughly I
mean there it is ding ding this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks Dr John deloney here with
some great great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become Healthy
Habits Like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow Hall is the number
one Prayer app in the world and they're
giving you 3 months free to get started
that's 3 months free to prioritize your
mental health and be intentional about
finding peace through calming music
prayers meditation and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition if
you don't have a faith tradition this is
a great place to learn more about it
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember halow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
8825 5225 so our team handed me this
this is cool George in March Andrew came
and did a debt-free scream with me and
uh Dr John deloney was on the air and we
celebrated him paying off three
$3,000 49 months wow his student loans
car debt home improvement loan credit
card and house paid off his home and
then we get an email from him that he
had a chance to go back to his alma
mater his high school to one of our
foundations in personal finance classes
warshaw high school and uh his he he put
this quote on Facebook 2009 whhs grad oh
that's what they put on there Andrew
returned to his Alma moer today to chat
with the senior financial planning class
about his financial journey and becoming
debt-free he completed the Dave Ramsey
class and paid off his debt this class
is also completing the high school
version of Financial Peace University
thanks for coming Andrew which is called
foundations and personal finance very
cool what a great poster child these
kids are going oh this I got to watch
another video and then they're seeing
this guy who was from their High School
who who graduated from the same sat at
the same desk they set who has no
payments in the world yeah at very young
age 100% debt free wow ding ding ding
ding house and everything and go in and
tell the high school seniors it can be
done that's how we do it see some social
proof yeah we've got the foundations and
personal finance High School curriculum
that now 6 million students have been
through since we started it it's been in
48% of the high schools it's currently
in like 40% of the high schools and more
and more states are now making personal
finance mandatory I love it and so so
we've been adopted by for instance the
Texas um what whatever the Texas state
school board or the adoption process to
adopt the curriculum uh and we were just
adopted in uh Florida oh that's right a
couple months ago a big one so Florida's
got a big push brand new push it's the
Texas has had it for a while and they've
got their second push coming to get all
the seniors before they graduate through
our kids before they graduate at some
point as a senior or Junior whatever
through a personal finance curriculum
and we have the largest most successful
one and Florida just adopted ours as
well now they've got other brands that
they can do but so now each of the
school local school boards are selecting
whether they're going to use Ramsey or
whether they're going to use something
else but really excited about it and um
um happy to be in Florida thanks Florida
we appreciate you and actually I got to
meet uh the state senator uh when we
were down there doing an event in or I
remember that I got to you were in the
you met him too he's in the Green Room
was incredible and that sponsored the
bill that got passed in Florida to uh
make personal finance a mandatory a man
it's not elect a mandatory class for
graduation at a certain date in Florida
high schools and that precipitates then
the uh High School curriculum our
personal finance curriculum is getting
adopted and we're one of the high school
approved adopted curriculums in in
Florida so excited about that so if
you're around one of the uh Florida uh
School boards or you're a teacher or
whatever um and you want to push for our
curriculum being in your school we would
appreciate it and way to go Andrew
thanks for going back to your school and
I don't know where washaw High School is
but it's not on this but it's pretty
cool that a guy does that and goes back
and speaks to the class with well
everyone going they don't teach us stuff
in school like we do now yeah it's it is
in a bunch of the states now and we're
that's obviously been doing it a very
very long time very successfully we meet
all the benchmarks it's a we've got a
educ Ramsey educ a Solutions Department
here that we've been running for I don't
know almost 20 years now and the guys
and gals in that department that that
put this curriculum together that we use
in the high schools uh are from the
education world and so our stuff meets
is the easiest for teachers to operate
because it's the lesson plans are done
the testing is done right it's all built
out to where it's it's as low lift as
possible former teachers going I wish
this is how it was created I wish
everything was created this way cuz our
guys are putting and it meets all the
educational benchmarks and legalities
and so forth that we have to meet in
order to be in a a public school system
and so we do every bit of that and uh
man we're just thrilled thrilled so many
people are getting able to do this and
this is cool that Andrew Andrew did that
that's a lot of fun Isaac is with us
Isaac is in Huntsville Alabama hi Isaac
welcome to the Ramsey
Show thanks for having me how are y'all
better than we deserve what's
up so my wife and I are fixing to be
going through our first
divorce and um she's going to keep the
house that we currently have and thanks
to a wonderful support system I'm going
to be able to move back in with my
parents while I get back on my feet and
at this point I'm just
wondering you know kind of what's next
how do I start over from here what
should be the correct Step I
Take
sorry I am 32 years old how long are
y'all
married uh about 5 years or so
maybe you have
children uh a 5-year-old son
yes I'm
sorry huh what do you
make um $33 an hour about $4,000 take
home a month
okay um
well to answer your
question you know you're you're just
going to start laying out a game plan to
build enough financial life that you
move into into this next chapter right I
mean first goal would be to get on your
feet enough that you had a little bit of
money saved and you go get an apartment
right right I mean this obviously your
parents are providing a a safety net not
a
hammock correct and so you're just
passing through and uh like you said
that's a wonderful thing and I'm not
upset about that at all but I would give
myself a number of months like three or
6 months or something and say by then
I'm going to have enough save to have
deposits and get an apartment get my own
place get some furniture you know get
get restarted in terms of like almost as
if you were moving out after high school
or college right right and um and then
you you know once you've kind of got a a
standard of living set and a place to
live then you start doing the baby steps
and you make sure you're you get out of
debt you build an emergency fund and you
know you start investing and you know
you're going to figure out that there's
another chapter to this life after 32
years old right right yeah so this
setback is going to be a comma not a
coma so keep that in your mind this is
temporary you're going to have a whole
another life on the other side of this
thing this doesn't Define you but it
will refine you and so now is a time to
make some choices that will set us up
for the next 10 years so do you know as
the dust settles what the financial
picture looks like as far as child
support alimony the house
debt so I will be taking the car that
she's currently driving and she's going
to take the car that I'm currently
driving because it's paid off and the
car that I will be getting is not I owe
somewhere around 21,000 on it um the way
we've worked everything out between us
you know everything's very
amicable so it's going to be uncontested
so the way we have it worked out no
child support no alimony or anything
it's all going to be you know we both
put in everything we can for him and
she's keeping the house and there's no
you're not getting any money out of this
out of the house
deal correct okay okay I'm not a lawyer
and I'm certainly not a lawyer in
Huntsville Alabama I don't think a judge
is going to approve a divorce decree
that does not in child include child
support okay uh you probably need some
legal advice not to create a stink but I
think you're going to be under the law
in Most states required to do something
for the kid from a legal perspective I
know you were going to from a moral
perspective but um but I I think I I
don't know I don't know what I'm talking
about so you need to check that out cuz
I had fireworks go off in my head but it
can't just be handshake agreements I
don't I don't think it can be I you
check me out I could be wrong okay so um
the house
what's the payment on the
house uh 550 a month what does she
make um bring home is about 2,000 a
month okay she's going to struggle with
that and your name still and your name's
still on the mortgage and if you try to
have a new life 5 years from now and she
hasn't paid the bills on time then your
credit is going to have been damaged so
I'm not sure this is a great plan
brother I know it sounds like it's all
nice it's all nice until it's not and
then when she gets in trouble loses her
job you're end up paying a house payment
for somebody you ain't married to
anymore cuz you're still on the mortgage
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show well you've all played the
telephone game the first person Whispers
a message to the second person who
Whispers it to the third and so on
around the table until the original
message has completely changed multiply
that confusion by a 100 if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsay we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
5225 you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your
money Johnny is with us in Irvine
California hi Johnny welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi there thank you for taking my
call how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up great well I'm calling
to see what you guys would do if you
were in my shoes I'm 22 years old I
fully support myself I take home about
$5,000 per month I have zero debt I have
$60,000 in savings a $3,000 emergency
fund and I've been listening for the
past year or so and some of my friends
and mentors are into long-term real
estate investing so I've been saving
towards that for the past couple of
years ideally I'd like to start building
some long-term wealth wealth and so I
just wanted to see what you guys would
do if you in my shoes wow you are beyond
beyond ahead of the game well done very
well done thank you well I um probably
have a different view on real estate
investing than your
mentors sure and I probably own more
than they
do given that I own about 600 million
worth okay um but anyway the uh uh I I
do not believe in borrowing money Johnny
because you and you've heard that
listening to the show and I don't for my
real estate investing I pay cash for it
and so so the first real estate
investing I did and I've always loved
real estate um that I did after going
broke and starting completely over and
with this new I don't borrow money thing
uh as a part of the guidelines uh was I
didn't do real estate investing at first
I just started piling money in mutual
funds and when I got enough in in an in
in an index fund is what I use an S&P
500 Index Fund when I it took me about
five years to buy my first income
producing property I paid cash for it
and then I took all of those
rents net of expenses and any other
money I could and I threw it in an index
fund until I had enough to buy another
property and then I took all the rents
from the two properties and any money I
could scrape together from anywhere else
book royalties or whatever else and I
bought another property for cash and
every time I bought another property for
cash I had more cash flow to buy another
property
faster than I did the one before does
that make any sense yeah that that makes
perfect sense that is a very long-term
play versus what you have been
considering until this phone
call sure because you're thinking about
getting up a down payment and going
buying a nice little duplex in
California exactly yeah and I'm telling
you to wait and pay cash for it which
your friends aren't going to like and I
don't really care they're wrong that's
true but you called knowing you were
going to get a different take which
tells me you're actually interested in
this
take I am yeah i' I've just been curious
what to do because I feel like I've I've
been saving decently and I'd like to
continue that um but you know once you
get a certain amount of money I feel
like it burns a little bit of a hole in
your pocket you're ready to jump into it
yeah and you've done really well Johnny
I mean let's face it you're 22 years old
you have 60,000 bucks in the in the bank
and no debt at all and you're making 5K
a month you're killing it dang dang very
impressive and it doesn't sound like you
lead a super luxurious lifestyle you're
a
saver I I try to be for sure there
there's a balance so the key is to keep
living on less than you make what would
be interesting if you want to be really
nerdy I don't know how nerdy you are I'm
real nerdy is and I've done this a
couple of times it's and it it always it
always works that's why I'm putting you
up to it is if you say all right when
I'm
42 would I rather own $10 million worth
of real estate with $8 million worth of
debt
or would I rather own $3 million worth
of paid for Real
Estate yeah I think the clear answer is
the 3 million yeah and then here's
what's here's the here's the exercise
run out the the purchase snowball which
is not a debt snowball but the way I
talked about a while ago rents buy more
buy more buy more buy more everything's
folded back into the next deal and the
slower start ends up with a faster
end these faster start ends up with a
slower
end my way is slower start but has a big
time payoff at the end because it hockey
sticks from an exponential mathematical
equation perspective does any of that
make
sense yeah definitely it does cuz when
you get all this property that's sitting
there paid for you are buying more
property faster than you would have if
you had a whole bunch of property that's
not even close to paid for and it's not
cash flowing nearly as
generously so the math says I can buy I
can buy more property faster now it's
ridiculous what my real estate fund now
looks like from my real estate
income you know now because I'm at the
back of the story right so but I can't
get people to to think long term and I
might have just got one 22y old to do it
though I'm impressed he sounded
interested yeah we can just get off Tik
Tok we'll get there for real
Jake is in De Mo Iowa hi Jake how are
you hey guys it's an honor to speak with
you thanks for having me our pleasure
how can we help sir yeah so I'm 35 years
old have no debt and am about to step
into baby step six and my question is uh
you talk about uh baby step seven living
and giving like no one else I have no
problem with the the giving aspect of
things the part that is a little tricky
for me to wrap my mind around is the
living like no one else because uh I am
a pastor and so to be stepping into baby
step seven hopefully here in the next
five or six years I'm trying to imagine
life in my 40s living like no one else
while being a pastor and and living in
the community of people who uh who pay
for who have paid for my uh financial
success you could say I I don't know how
else you would put it but how how should
I think through that as I look forward
to the next five or 10 years yeah
well
um don't muzzle the ox as he Treads out
the grain you probably read that
scripture right yeah and a worker is
worthy of his
hire you probably read that scripture
right so are you a good pastor and
you're worth what they pay
you I I sure hope so then if you use
that money wisely in Christianity we
would call that good stewardship
wouldn't we
and I think you're modeling for those
people what good Steward what the
results of good stewardship are that it
ends up with
wealth but we're taught by
the by Carl Marx not by Jesus that
wealth is
evil wealth is not evil people are
evil particularly some of them in your
church I'm kidding
no but but uh not much but yeah
anyway but yeah but but so you're always
going to have a hater whether you win or
you lose if you do it at
scale yeah if you lose you weren't a
good Steward and you're horrible and you
worked your whole life and you have
nothing to show for it and we call that
being a good Steward that's not a good
Steward that means you did a bad job
handling your
money so you're supposed to model for
your congregation how to how to be a
good husband how to be a good dad right
right how to be a great leader we're
supposed to model in Christian it's
called a witness we call And yet when it
my my friend Craig Rochelle says why is
it that wealth is the only blessing from
God we're supposed to apologize
for and I've got several friends that
are pastors that are uh a decade and a
half ahead of you and they're facing the
exact same thing because they have
systematically carefully invested in uh
in their 401ks and in their Roth IRAs
and in their retirement programs and
some of them have bought real estate
carefully and they they don't have jet
airplanes they're not on TV you know
that it's none of that junk they're just
good guys as a pastor and they've been
careful with their income and most of
them are millionaires because they did
the stuff I teach but now there's always
some duber that says well a pastor
should never be a millionaire yeah
that's what I want I want my pastor to
be broke and
stupid no I don't either I want my P I
don't want I want you know Pastor should
never listen I want my pastor I want his
marriage to be something I can look up
to I want his kids to be something I can
look up to I want the way he handles
money to be something I can look up to
because obviously the book he is reading
has having an effect on his life and I
want to know more about what that book
called The Bible says then but not if
you're out you know so but you're always
going to be criticized Jake whether it's
about your message or the car you drive
there going to be someone out there ex
and you know you have to get if you're a
Christian you have to drive a used
Accord cuz that's what Jesus said they
were all in one Accord oh that one still
gets me this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey George camel here if you love
the show and you want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsey Way just go to ramsy Solutions
today to sign up for the newsletter
again that's ramsy solutions.com to sign
up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships open phones at
trip8 825
5225 that's
5225 Jenna start oh George camel Ramsey
personality is my co-host today uh he's
also the co-host of smart money happy
hour and the host of The George camel
show on YouTube which is exploding by
the way one of our more popular ramsy
Network launches in the last year Jenna
is with us Jenna is in Seattle
Washington hi Jenna welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi oh my gosh I'm so excited
to talk to you guys you too what's
up um so I have a situation that feels
complicated to me but likely not to you
guys which is why I'm calling um I am
the soulle provider for my family and am
selfemployed as a um therapist I'm
mental health therapist in private
practice and um I make uh good money
over 200 $100,000 a year and um um yeah
over 10 years it's been it's been
amazing um but um I'm paid pretty
irregularly mostly by insurance
companies and um I usually know by like
Sunday evenings um kind of what my
deposits are going to look like but they
tend to um be slightly different um each
week and then I also get kind of random
payments like you know co- payments from
patients or just um kind of paper checks
it's just I'm not I don't have like a
it's it's sort of predictable but like
also not predictable how long you been
doing
this uh how long have I been doing this
over 10 years uh actually so over the
over the course of a year it's very
predictable over the course of six
months it's fairly predictable over the
course of one week it's not correct okay
so give us some uh rough estimate here
what's your question so we're struggling
to budget
um as far as um the kind of grocery
shopping um weekly versus monthly like
just kind of really trying to understand
our money better um we've kind of banked
on like we just make good money and so
we money just sort of disappears and I'm
trying to do better we're trying my
husband and I are trying to do better um
my one caveat question I want to throw
him under the bus is he also refuses to
drop the coffee stand and wants to keep
it in the budget and I want to mix it
from the budget um so I want you guys to
give some uh you mean buying a cup of
coffee at a coffee stand correct this is
not your problem no it's not my problem
you need to lose that battle and win the
war he needs a budget line item for his
coffee he gets his coffee and we get a
budget together that we both work on
that accomplishes our overall goals
coffee is not keeping you from doing
that I agree all right that one's under
the bus he you lose he wins next all
right George how do we do an irregular
income so the simplest way to look at
this is look at what a low month would
be for you guys we know it's it's not
going to be zero right correct so what
would be a low
month a low month would be 12,000 okay
so we start there we'll input that in
the budget and when more money comes in
we'll just add that income into the
budget on the income side got me okay
yes then on the expense side we're going
to do it a little differently because
it's a regular we're going to make a
prioritized spending plan so let's have
our four walls we got to cover the bills
you know the rent the mortgage all of
that stuff first food on the table you
should have a set food budget that is
fixed that easily fits within
$112,000 and it should not have to
change based on the irregularity of the
income okay other things will change
based on the irregularity but not food
okay because it's first now are you at
risk of running out of money even on
that bad month of $122,000 or are you
just trying to go hey we should be
saving more with all of our expenses
well um no we're not at risk of running
out of money um I just don't feel like
we're throwing enough at our snowballs
um we have perfect yeah we're not at
risk of running out of money as far as
our our needs go I just feel like it
every after that it sort of just
disappears gotcha but it's not
disappearing into the coffee stand
there's other places under other money
leaks well it's what she's saying I
think and I don't put words in your
mouth is it's disappearing into the
disorganization and the chaos and I want
to get a handle on this so I can feel
like I'm doing a good job correct like
it's like one week I'll I'll pay the
Comcast bill and then the next week I'll
pay you know a different bill and I just
don't feel like I'm organized enough um
and so I feel like you know I want to
have a better understanding and I was
thinking similar to what you were saying
if I just created an idea budget and
then whatever kind of comes extra I
could even just throw out our snowball
um if you can live on the
12,000 without touching it and you get
everything you need to do you could run
a budget on 12,000 000 and every extra
dollar above that goes to your debt
snowball that's an easy
fix okay if you need 13,000 to live but
12 is your low then you've got to add a
thousand to those last few things before
you start the debt snowball that's what
George is saying yeah so including our
business expenses we need about 9,000 to
live 9 to 10,000 to live okay your
business needs to be running
separately yeah yeah yeah yeah the
business is running separately um
no no no noop STP stop you don't have an
included okay the it's not it's not
running separately if it's included
hello so here here's the thing we run a
business budget and then when we bring
money home from our net profits after
paying the business
expenses then we work with that so your
business expenses run
what my business expenses are monthly is
only
uh $2,300 a month okay all right so you
actually have a low of
9700 yes because you're not bringing
home that
2300 correct okay so you know so so that
based on what we're I need to have you
need to have that separated out and keep
it set completely separate run a
separate set of books separate checking
account separate everything for the
business actually give ourselves a
weekly paycheck we give ourselves but
that doesn't matter you got to you got
and then you need to cash out the rest
of the profits beyond your weekly
paycheck and beyond your expenses out of
the business account over into the
personal account but the same principle
will still work because the same math
applies I just split it aparts all okay
so you're still okay 9700 will still do
it if 2300 stayed at the office you can
still do it on 9700 and everything else
will go to the Deb snowball and then
some so in the 9700 some of it's going
to the Deb snowball but it's just how
much more we put on the Deb snowball and
every every dollar premium will cause
you to be able to do that we've got a
thing in there called paycheck planning
uh that works really well for the
irregular income and you and your
husband can sit down together and lay
the whole thing out on the app uh or on
the desktop whichever you choose to do
with every dollar and it'll lay all out
and and we'll give you three months free
and get you started on the every dollar
premium okay a awesome cool thank you
guys all right hang on um we'll have the
team pick up and give you three months
for every dollar premium cuz that'll
that'll do it perfectly oh yeah and
it'll help him see where's all money
going what did we decide we were going
to do this month yeah and then the only
choice you're making is $8 or whatever
the flipping coffee is it's ridiculous
but I mean $8 is not going to get you
out of debt that are but but you are
going to start looking at everything
including the coffee you'll see how much
money was how much more can we throw how
far are we going to cut our lifestyle
versus the debt we have versus the
$200,000 well not really
$175,000 income that we have this is the
ram
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now to get up
to 50% off that's blinds.com
rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones
5225 I was just telling George a story
and Austin you need to hear this too in
2012 I took a call here on the air from
a guy who had a side hustle and he said
I love my side hustle more than I like
my job when can I quit my job and do the
side hustle I want to double down my
parents say I'm crazy for doubling down
my wife says I'm half crazy for quitting
my job uh he was a pharmacist so he'
spent a lot of money and a lot of time
getting to to be a pharmacist and he he
said I want to quit Pharmacy I want to
go into this whole other side of things
in the gun industry and I'm like okay so
I'm I'm a gun guy so I'm talking to him
and listening to him I'm like yeah
that's pretty cool so I said how much do
you make and he said I made 65,000 on my
side hustle how much you make as a
pharmacist this year this is 2012 he
said 60,000 I said well double down I'm
on your team uh I I if I would advise
your wife that you should go after this
it's what you love it's your passion uh
I would advise your mom and dad that
they're very sweet but they're wrong and
that you should go after this so um a
couple weeks ago I was out west and um I
visited the guy's
business he did 70 million last
year that hurts my brain
wow and he acts like I did it and I'm
like I didn't do anything I talked to
you for five minutes you've worked for
uh you know what 11 12 years on your
business you built your business I
didn't build your business I'm so proud
of you though uh I I'll take credit for
lighting a fire but dude you you you
burned the forest down man that way to
go way to go man that's pretty cool uh
we don't always get to hear the followup
11 years later to taking some you guys
calls out here so uh some of you ought
to tell us if we screwed it up 12 years
later or if we got if we got it right or
whatever yeah goodness pretty cool
pretty cool I'm I'm impressed with him
sharp young guy too obviously Todd is in
Fort Wayne hey Todd welcome to the
Ramsey Show he Dave thanks for taking my
call sure what's up got a quick question
for you uh back in 2009 2010 when
there's a big recession that we all
heard about my business uh went in
pretty deep and uh since then I've paid
back uh everybody I can and taken care
of all that but I've got one credit card
that went after me and in 2000 it
through Collections and uh it took me to
small I guess you call it small claims
court because I seen I got a letter for
a judgment against me but at that time
um I was still trying to get my head
above water how long ago was the
Judgment uh it was 2015 August of 2015
so eight years ago okay was the first
one yes uh the first one yeah the amount
was about um I don't know $23,000 but of
course with all their fees that judgment
was for 8,000 round numbers and uh
anyway I just got another certified
letter today I didn't know how to for
sure uh how to contact these guys I just
knew it was out there but they've added
2,000 to it um anyway it says they have
14 days to congest um I'm assuming a
court hearing I didn't know the first
time I could do that but do I just think
they I don't think they'll get to have a
court hearing on this one okay because
it's gone too long yeah all right so
let's do a little uh let's learn a
couple things here number one you owe
these people some money and you're not
disputing that agreed yes okay yes and
the original balance was
what uh I don't know for sure it was
like 3,000 or something with their fee
the original no I'm talking about fees
I'm talking about what you actually owe
them oh the first one was uh $79.97 so
8,000 no no no no no no that was with
the
fees okay when you had a credit card
before it went to collections the
balance on the credit card was $3,000
wasn't it yeah somewhere around there
yeah that's what I'm thinking okay
so um here's the thing if they said
they've added more another 2,000 so it's
now $10,000 right yes okay there's a
whole industry out there that most
people don't even know is out there
called debt
buyers and they buy old
bad probably
uncollectable debt probably
uncollectible because the person has
already filed bankruptcy and they don't
get anything but they still will buy the
debt sometimes not knowing that uh or
the debt has gone too long and it's
passed the statute of limitations in
that county or that City or that town or
that state and so it's not collectible
which I think is probably the case with
yours anyway they probably get zero uh
technically legally uh but they buy old
bad debt now let me tell you what they
pay for
it a nickel on the
dollar maybe less yeah so this guy
calling you or certified lettering you
is with a $110,000 bill likely has $250
to $500 invested in your
account
okay that's good information if you're
going to call him and offer him 3 ,000
bucks yeah I want to do right by this
debt I'm willing to pay
$3,000 that's all I'm willing to pay if
you want $1 more I'm going to give that
to a lawyer and I'm going to fight you
to the death because I don't think you
can collect this at all because it's
gone too
long so this is a case this letter from
the our County Courthouse or uh Court
does that make a difference nope it's
not the court didn't buy the debt some
duber bought the debt okay so the the
dubers brought you to the county
courthouse you got a is a dubers name on
there uh yeah the collection agency and
there's a lawyer name on it the lawyer
is who you call call the lawyer okay
because here's the deal they are not in
the business this is not like if I owed
you money and you were pissed and got a
lawyer and sued me okay this is a
conveyor belt at a factory and it's the
junkyard it's not even a factory it's a
conveyor belt at the junkyard and
they're running like 9,000 Parts a
minute down the conveyor belt and you're
one tiny little
part okay all right let me give you
another example just to for fun okay a
couple of Christmases ago I decided to
take advantage of this knowledge to do a
fun charitable thing for our team we
bought 8,000 accounts from a debt buyer
totaling $10 million worth of debt our
purpose in buying it was was we were
going to call all 8,000 people we have
1,000 employees so each of them got to
call eight people and tell them their
debt is Forgiven in Jesus name for
Christmas so we bought $10 million worth
of debt to do that for
$259,000 two and a. half cents on the
dollar yeah that's amazing yeah so I'm
telling you this is how this works so
that that's who you're dealing with
you're one of 8,000 in a package only
you didn't the package wasn't bought by
me so you got to go deal with the people
but it's still I had
8,000 people that were in this one
package for two and a half cents on
2.59 cents on the
dollar all right and that that's how
this that's how this industry works man
so and what do they want they want more
than they've got in it because this is a
business for them not a charitable event
so they got 250 or500 Grand $500 in your
deal you offer them 3,000 and you stand
firm and argue with them about 30 times
they're going to take it get it in
writing do not give them electronic
access to your checking account those
two things are very
important okay so I think you should pay
them what you owe them which is three
grand okay you got the three grand yep I
do very cool how does that does that
tell you what you need to know yes
perfect thank you cool thank you so
they're hoping a few people in this
giant pile will pay that eight or 10
grand to make this whole lot a work no
they they never get
it 99% of the accounts aren't
collectible that's why they're worth
nothing because I mean what do you what
are the chances of collecting on
something from 2010 13 years ago 13
years ago if you can even find the guy I
mean they're just saying Glory
Hallelujah that they even found him
right we had trouble making the calls we
couldn't even old cell phone numbers bad
numbers we had a we you know we had what
I bet you uh one out of uh one out of
eight was probably bad or two out of
eight the information we had with the
accounts we bought were bad which tells
you they had bad information when they
bought it well yeah cuz it's old I mean
how many people got the same cell phone
number 13 years later you know and or
whatever the same address and you know
you don't send a change of address to
people you owe money to if you're on the
run you know so it doesn't happen that
way so it's an interesting world but
it's a very high doll high number low
performance world and if you'll keep
that in mind when you're dealing with
them it's not personal it's just a
transaction for them this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey guys being free to make your
own medical decisions is a big deal
these days Christian Healthcare
Ministries gives members the freedom to
choose the doctors and providers they
want without the frustration of worrying
about networks and with no waiting
period to join it's a membership-based
nonprofit Ministry where hundreds of
thousands of Christians share funds to
pay for and pray for each other's
medical bills for over 40 years chm has
helped families living across all 50
states so see if chm could be right for
your family check out more today at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at 88
25225 today's question of the day
sponsored by neighborly your home for
home your hub for Home Services
neighborly can help you find local
service pros like the Grounds Guys
five-star Painting and More to get your
outdoor space ready for the cooler
months download the neighborly app today
and get started today's question comes
from Steve in Minnesota I'm 43 years old
I still have student loan debt about
4,900 it was originally 24 Grand back in
2010 this year in May I went and got
2,130 hair graph transplants for about
13 Grand some I paid up front and the
rest I used a Care Credit Card for
$10,500 I owe about five grand on it now
I have 32,000 in savings I've got about1
Grand in a 401k and I make about 20
bucks an hour I didn't get enough hair
graphs to cover the back top crown area
should I go back from more hair
transplant graphs to cover that
area Dave this is a personal question
that I think think only you could
answer this is very personal it's
personal you're just mean hair jokes
George well you've bullied me for far
too long days my time to get
back oh Steve Steve Steve okay Steve
Steve Steve well the good news is Steve
has some money and he can clean up this
debt today I don't know why he's waited
13 years yeah he has 32 Grand in savings
let's knock out the 10 grand in debt and
you'll still have 22,000 left that
covers an eer emergency fund and that
should cover some hair graphs so 32,000
10,500 on the credit card he says he ow
was five on it now and then um oh okay
and then five so so 10,000 clears up the
student loan and the card right yep and
that leaves him
$22,000 right MH that's what I'm saying
okay and um then we need to ascertain
what your emergency fund should be 3 to
6 months of
expenses and if that is under
$22,000 like say 15 then you would have
seven you could use towards other things
and if that's what you choose to do with
your money okay um right yeah but if
your if your emergency fund should be
25,000 you need to finish your emergency
fund before you do other things because
until you're out of debt and have an
emergency fund in place we do not
do elective surgeries that's a luxury
it's a luxury well I need bigger
lips no no the food's going in you don't
need bigger lips the uh coffee is not
spilling you need bigger you don't need
bigger lips uh you can bigger lips are a
luxury uh hair in the back is a luxury
apparently hair in the front is a luxury
for so he must have got just the front
done and then he's got this Crown here
that's still I mean if you're the hair
transplant people that was genius hey
you'll have to come back leaves you it
leaves you with a a guaranteed client
for the back as soon as they get home
and get a mirror the other question is
they do a good job with the rest of it
so far cuz maybe let's not go back my
stomach is in my throat this is killing
me but yeah but I imagine it's a few
more Grand to finish it up if he's got
the crown left I'm going to get in a lot
of trouble if I'm not real careful here
but anyway the um yeah if this is what
you want to do with your money it should
only be done it's a choice it's a luxury
item it's like buying a new couch or
upgrading a car it's done after your
emergency fund is in place and you are
debt free so you should write a check
today Steve and pay off your student
loan debt and your credit card I'm is
this even is this real this is some guy
spook I thought Austin was trolling us
somebody's punking us and Austin let it
through it's too specific to be punking
at this point well it's a good way to
pun somebody You' give great detail like
I just don't have enough hair graphs in
the many hair graphs
2,130 I know but that's pretty that's
how you punk somebody that's how that's
what causes us to bite on it well we bid
on it and so we're pretending like it's
real I think someone wanted to know your
take on hair transplant oh that's just
no no they didn't obviously they know my
take on hair transplant all they got to
do is just pull up say not worth the
money well it's just um it's a yeah
you've been cutting your own hair for a
a few decades now it's easier that way I
the amount of money you've saved though
compared to me I just grew up in a
different place and a different time
where we enjoyed getting old and we is
what we is so we didn't constantly be
poking and prodding at ourselves but
it's a different time back then it was
just like a t pay there weren't many
options yeah that's true it's a bad two
pay or nothing yeah like something out
of a movie from the 70s yeah but oh I
don't I I figured that the person with
the lowest hair maintenance and the
highest hair mainten Main in the studio
we' have opinion would have a great
opinion on this Jade's not
here touche boom roasted
Jade hey Jade spends more time on her
hair than you do I promise you I've got
this down to a size she's got more stuff
going on from the Predator look to the
twisted up on top look to the whole
thing she's got more looks I'll tell you
this I haven't spent 13 Grand on my hair
so there's a bonus yeah none of all of
us together have not spent 13 Grand on
our hair so I would just start wearing
hats or just let it ride man I mean you
got a great head for it Dave not
everyone has that see George you're
trying to dig out now you're trying to
dig out I'll never dig out get you a
shovel buddy this is my last show
America it's been shovel buddy it's been
fun yeah you you and Austin Austin
brings in the hair joke email an aloop
and you just you you you do the stuff
with it right you just stuff the thing
right yeah all right let's move on while
I still have my job all right Sarah is
in Nashville hi Sarah welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi thanks for having me sure what's
up okay so I work two jobs I work a
full-time job and then I also work a
part-time job um my question is should I
or like is it okay for me to quit my
part-time job um even though I'm in baby
step too um the reason I'm wanting to
quit it is basically because I'm working
all the time you know I'm trying to be
gazelle intense and all but I am not
having a good time and I want to pursue
like other things to eventually go into
that so like what are you
saying basically I want to in the long
run get into music and I am in Nashville
so it's like the perfect place to do
that you want to get into music did you
say yes okay all right but and what's
your part-time gig now I'm in retail
okay all right well that's like most of
Nashville yeah I mean like how do you
get the next country music stars
attention in Nashville uh
waiter right I mean that that's they're
everywhere I've got I've got three
people that were on The Voice working
for me and they ain't doing voice I'm
telling you so um but anyway the uh uh
yeah it's it's everywhere and I'm not
saying you can't do it you you should do
it but how much debt do you have
left I have about
50,000 and it's student loans okay and
when at your current rate with gazelle
intensity when will that be
done um about 2ish years how old are you
28 okay how many hours a week are you
working
now um about 15 hours extra
so and plus a 40-hour job yes okay so
where do you work on Saturday
night um retail retail's not
open yeah correct so I'm not working
yeah where do you work on Friday night
not at retail it's not
open well I work the retail job uh
Monday through Friday after work and
they close all right so you don't have a
Saturday gig okay yeah so sing on
Saturday yeah so I guess it's a little
bit complicated because I'm not into
like the country music scene I'm more
into Christian you're in Nashville and
you want to get into music you want to
be in the Christian music is that what
you said yes okay so how are you
planning on breaking into
it that's a good question I'm not
exactly sure I'm also thinking like the
social media rout okay then I would do
that on
Saturdays okay and I get plugged into a
church where that music's happening as
well yeah make sure you're in a good
church that's Musical and they're doing
a lot of good praise and worship stuff
and you know Nashville is also the home
of contemporary Christian music for sure
most of the artists live here that do
that for a living a lot of them are
friends okay uh the older ones are
friends your buddy Darren Tyler did a
songwriting night at his church with a
bunch of songwriters so there's stuff
like this happening in the community all
the time you can do all of that and
still keep your retail job you just got
to give up partying on Saturday oh wait
a minute you're doing this from a
Christian perspective maybe partying
isn't the problem um you got to shut
down the prayer group on Saturday night
and go do something else kind of party
yeah that's it so yeah I I think you can
find the time Sarah and I think it's a
short-term play to get out of debt let's
get out of
debt
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other play places won't touch and gives
you a custom loan built for you based on
your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Walt is in Buffalo New
York hey Walt welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it sure what's up uh actually
had two questions but the young lady on
the the screener told me I could only
ask one so I figur I'd mention it maybe
you guys let me squeak in too uh my wife
and I have been on the baby steps since
November of
2022 we made it all the way to step
three and almost immediately after that
we had to use a couple thousand doll of
our emergency
fund uh we have
$4,000 in a high yield savings account
that's earmarked for kids college uh
he's 10 right now and we're wondering if
we should take the 2,000 from that four
to fill the emergency refund back
up I
would uh because it's not in a college
fund it's just earmarked you you have
two accounts one of them you got named
college but you got a 10-year-old you
got plenty of time to build their
college savings and doing it in a 529
and so forth that's exactly what I would
do yeah simple enough I mean it's liquid
you're not going to pay any penalties so
if you told me it was in a 529 I'd say
don't touch it yeah but you're you'll be
fine there and you'll have time to fill
it back or if it had been there for 20
years or something and the kid was seven
I mean you know there's a lot of
different factors but uh you got a lot
of time and it's just a it's just a
right pocket left pocket thing um and
then just you know if you take it out of
the right pocket put in the left pocket
then you got to go back to the right
pocket and fill it up which is baby step
five anyway reminder well four five and
six are done
simultaneously yep so we're investing
15% while we have that plate spinning we
begin to fund the kids college then any
money left over we can throw onto the
mortgage to pay that off early yeah so
four five and six which is retirement
savings kids college savings and paying
the house off early we run
simultaneously but still in that order
15% going into retirement funding kids
college which you're going to do
immediately uh you'll begin with that
with that 2,000 left over and get an
account open and get it moving and then
if you find more money in your budget or
as you find more money in your budget as
you go along let's pay off the house
early Elijah is with us in Charlotte
North Carolina Hi Elijah welcome to the
r
show hey Dave thanks for having us sure
what's
up so me and my wife have a question and
it is we are debt free we have an
emergency fund we've tried to do
everything by the book and both of us
have zero credit and we are renting
currently is there any way that we could
one day buy a house without any credit
what is your
advice well George did it yeah it's a a
fairly simple Le process it's called
manual underwriting and what that is is
basically a no score loan and our
friends at Churchill Mortgage have been
doing this forever but if you tell
anyone about it they'll say no you can't
do that and even if they say you can
they'll say it's so much more expensive
it's such a headache it'll take you
forever they're lying they've never done
it so let me tell you from someone who's
done it that it's simple but you have to
do it by the book like you mentioned so
you're going to want to have all the
documentation your verification of
income rental payment history you know
12-month history of your bank statements
a tax return things like that and along
with that you need to have a good down
payment have you guys started saving
that up
yet yes as soon as we finish building up
our emergency fund that's what we were
going to start on awesome so I would aim
to have a minimum of 10% if you're doing
the no score loan 20% is even better to
avoid that private mortgage insurance
what kind of budget are you looking for
for a
house right now we're in North Carolina
and the hous of markets anywhere from
100 or $200,000 to
$300,000 great so let's set that goal
and we'll set it down down payment
savings goal and as long as you can get
that payment to be 25% of your take-home
pay of your after tax income per month
on a 15year fixed then you're ready to
buy a
home sounds great thank you so much
again Elijah if you go to a traditional
mortgage company or you ask your
friends um they're all going to tell you
that because they don't know how to do
it that that can't be done George did it
Jade did it Dr John deloney did it all
of our Ramsey personalities have had
zero credit scores gone and got
mortgages okay so it it definitely can
be done we'll put a link to uh the
Ramsey Solutions blog about this in the
show notes and so if you want to go back
and pull that up out of the show notes
you'll be able to do that with a great
detail on it but really George just gave
it all to you and again gave selecting a
mortgage company that knows what the
flip they're doing that's important and
most of them don't Churchill Mortgage
does know how to do this Chaz is with us
in Orlando hi Chaz welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
up uh so my question is I'm 24 years old
me and my fiance are getting married
next February um I have zero debt right
now um and I have a nice little mesake
in the bank that I've been saving up um
my question is my fiance has some debt
once we get married do you recommend
that I kind of use up most of my Nest
Egg to pay off her debt or should we
keep that Nest EG in the bank and just
keep pursuing paying off her debt now
that we've have both incomes to pay it
off what are we talking in the
bank so right now I have about $34,000
in the bank um and then her debt is a
little bit over
$117,000 okay um so it wouldn't totally
wipe it out but it's just you know we
now through February it's just you know
no I don't know what do you mean you
know for I I mean yeah but like we just
like to have it in the bank no you do
for like yes you worked hard to save
this money up and it hurts emotionally
to Let It Go for someone else's
mistake yeah that's okay to say out loud
but just know when you get married
you're signing up for that whole
person's life and it's our money so now
you have debt as well it's our debt and
it's our income all of the mistakes you
have made come with you all of the
mistakes she has made come with her and
the preacher will say and now you are
one
mistake so this is how this works
brother are you that in love with her
that you're willing to do this oh 100%
not even a second when you get home from
the honeymoon write a check and pay off
for student
loan okay yeah period period no question
about it and she should be paying it
down you know we've got to save up for
the wedding are you guys paying for
it no luckily her parents have blessed
us with paying for the wedding great so
that's been a huge blessing for sure
wonder and she's totally she's paying
paying it down we've actually been
taking your class through our church and
good so she's already working it down
like every single day um but it just it
looks like there might be a little bit
left over once we get married and so you
know I was calling in to see see what
your opinion was on so Chaz here here's
the thing if you called us up you you've
listened to us or you've been through
Financial Peace University if you called
us up and said we're a married couple we
have $344,000 in savings and we have
$177,000 in a student
loan we instantaneously would tell you
to pay that off wouldn't
we yes you would okay the only Nuance
here is is that it's new because the
marriage will be at that time new so
that's the only nuance and what you're
facing here is you're really having to
face this idea that we are going to
combine our incomes our dreams our fears
our mistakes our assets we're going to
combine everything and we're going to
become a whole new entity called a
married couple and that and you're this
is forcing you to process the emotions
of that which to georg's point you know
we we poke fun but but it's they're very
real it's a very real emotion yeah and
so but you've listened to us enough to
know that if you were answering the
question as you're driving along in the
car while listening on talk radio uh and
someone else called in you would be
going they're going to tell him to pay
the loan
off yes that's true so the only
difference here is it wasn't an existing
marriage couple we're moving into it and
that's the only Nuance to change it
happens to be your money this time
rather than listening to someone else to
call in that changes it too that's tough
but you know the beautiful thing is you
also get to build wealth together and it
is like exponentially greater when you
have two people who are on the same page
oh yeah yeah that there's what's called
in uh sociological studies and economic
studies that called the marriage
advantage M the P you know the there's
several marital advantages uh if you
haven't read the the research that's out
there uh Health M males who are married
live longer wow yeah uh and couples who
are married have a wealth and an income
career career and income Advantage
statistically they make more money and
they have more money statistically so
it's called the marriage Advantage
research projects that are out there
floating around very interesting to look
at so yeah you're right this is going to
go zoom zoom you're going to be fine
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the
[Music]
books hey it's George camel if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsey Baby Steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships George camel
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
I'm Dave Ramsey the phone number Isle
5225 starting off this hour is Corey in
Cleveland Ohio hi Corey how are you good
how you doing better than I deserve
what's up so I got a question I I got
$35,000 in credit card debt I'm going
through a divorce uh she wants me to
take another half of hers and I um I I'm
struggling I'm working um five days a
week um I drive truck as a local truck
driver and I just don't know where to
where you going to start
at okay
um how much debt do you guys have as a
couple you've got 35 how much does she
have it'll be 65,00 total so she has
another 30 yes okay and there car
payments uh yes I have a car payment my
my truck payment is 970 a month good God
all right and um how much is her car
payment uh her car payment I'm not too
sure that we're actually we're going
through a divorce and we're separated at
this
time well dude you were married to her
did you have the car
then yeah yeah well she had uh she had
given me my car back I had bought her a
Lexus at the time and she had give it
back to me stuck me with that and my
truck payment plus a motorcycle payment
and I was struggling so I traded both of
my vehicles in and end up purchasing the
truck I have now I saved myself about
$500 a month doing that yeah you didn't
go far enough all right no I didn't all
right
um okay so the problem is is we're
working out all the debts before there's
a deal cut MH so every time you every
time you get something paid off or
figured out she hands you another one
yes now this has got to
stop you've already eaten a Lexus in a
motorcycle and now she wants you to eat
15 more of the debt that's the credit
card debt that's in her name yes okay so
we need to uh do you guys have an
attorney yeah we have we both have
attorneys I I tried T own her I I she
keep the house and everything we put
into it she keeps her dead I keep mine
go her separate ways and she's not into
it she has no she's not willing to work
with me at
all okay then I guess the judge is going
to have to decide right and that comes
February 7th I'm trying to figure out
what I need to do in the meantime I have
an opportunity right now to buy my own
semi and go over the road and make what
I'm making now you need to get this
cleared up before you do that because
she's going to end up with half the dad
gum semi right that's what I'm worried
about yeah how much money do you have in
the bank uh at this moment in time I'm
strug one and that's what I'm I have
maybe 30 bucks right now I'm going
through it right
now
okay and you're not driving over the
road now or you
are you just cut out on me man uh that's
why we were uh that's why we're going to
the divorce we drove team over the road
together me and her together uh we were
racking down 250,000 a year between us
both um I was sticking mine in my 401 K
she was spending hers and that's another
thing she's wanting she's wanting half
of my 401k also and we weren't even
married that long three years and she's
entitled to uh everything I put in from
the date of marriage to the date of
divorce which it's not even it's not
really a lot of money but I worked for
it you know you guys have kids no kids
nope okay so are you driving over the
road now no I'm local okay what do you
make
uh right now I'm 3322 an hour and that
is all straight pay and you've got an
apartment yes okay what's the house
worth uh I just had an appraise at
appraise for
174,000 what do you owe on
it uh
132 okay all right so here's here's what
I would do all right the problem with a
divorce is it turns a marriage into a
business transaction
MH and so this is now a list of debts
and a list of assets that must be
negotiated through the law in Most
states as you have found out splits it
down the middle what she wants doesn't
matter what you want doesn't matter the
law is going to demand that you split it
down the middle if you come to something
close to that and pre- agree to it the
judge will approve it if you come to
something way out of balance the judge
is probably not going to approve it and
kick out your agreed to settlement
because it's too
stupid okay so all of that to say you
don't need to be buying anything if I
were in your shoes I'd sell this
truck yeah get you yeah you said that
like I'm not doing it you need to sell
your stupid truck dude $970 at $33 an
hour is in the cray cray zone right I I
want to get rid of it I went to trade it
in they told me I would have to pay out
$4,000 in equity negative Equity to
could get off from underneath the truck
at that point
do go go borrow 4,000 at the credit
union and do it or sell a private party
if you can make 4,000 more and be get
out of it clean sell it private and and
just sell it and be done with it
somebody will give you more than you owe
on it okay what is it what kind of truck
is it it's a 2023 Chevy
Silverado that's a beast that's a good
Truck Yeah you ought to be able to get
more than you owe on it yeah so yeah the
problem is a dealer thinks he's got you
coming again
right he got you last time he's going to
get you again especially if you're
desperate they can smell that off you
yeah so I think I think you put it on
them look it up on Kelly Blue Book and
sell it for more than you owe on it and
then get you a hoopty because you're
driving truck during the day anyway you
don't need a bank big car right now you
got more problems than you need car
right yes sir so this is temporary one
year from the day everything's going to
be changed but temporarily you've gotten
rid of the car now you're down to only3
$5,000 worth a credit card debt and
negotiating with your soon Tobe ex-wife
over the 401K in the house yes cuz the
credit card debts going to be split down
the middle you're going to get your 35
she's going to get her 30 you're
probably going to give up half your 401k
or you can give her a credit towards the
house and sell the
house right how much is in the
401K uh 35 35,000 so 17 of the equity in
the house can go to her instead of
giving up your 401
and sell the house and give her her half
plus 17 which is probably almost the
whole thing but don't let the house stay
in the deal do not do not let her have
the house because you're on the mortgage
and then she doesn't pay it you're
screwed right Force the sale of the
house split the proceeds minus your half
of the 401K that you're going to have to
give up anyway and that way your 401k
stays
intact you walk out of this with a 401k
and only $35,000 wor a credit card debt
and a hoop
now you can talk about going over the
road and making some money and clean up
the 35,000 right
quick okay but you're being managed by
emotion because your heart's broken one
minute you're pissed the next minute and
you're broke and terrified the next
minute yes sir I understand man I've
been there it's no fun and so I I hav
been through the divorce part of it been
through the rest of it though and it is
no fun so laying out a detailed fact
actual game plan with math removes some
of the emotion from it and that's what I
just gave you so go back and listen to
this on YouTube or on podcast or however
so I because I gave you the exact plan
of what to do and and what I what I laid
out is negotiable and if she won't do it
take it before the judge he'll make her
do it this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
so one of the most popular things we
have done in many years is about two
months ago we started doing free
webinars with Jade marshaw Rachel Cruz
and George camel each of them doing free
webinars with the every doll budgeting
app showing you how to build out your
budget why to build out your budget and
uh couples are jumping on for free and
watching the webinar and you can
interact with the webinar you can
actually ask questions live live chat a
Q&A Box live chat while we're going and
a what box a Q&A box Q box so you throw
stuff in so there's interaction it's not
just George squawking at you or Jade or
Jade or Rachel squawking at you and uh
so we're doing these free online
budgeting trainings uh go to
everydollar.com
budgeting and between now and the end of
the year each one of those three will be
doing three or four of these and so
George Rachel Jade uh you can jump on
choose which one or just pick the night
or day or whatever that the time is
convenient for you it's completely free
very interactive very helpful on the
every dollar budgeting app on how to get
a plan together cuz if you don't have a
plan you know it's like Zig Ziggler used
to say if you aim at nothing you'll hit
it every time and my friend John Maxwell
says a budget is people telling their
money what to do instead of wondering
where it went every
dollar.com budgeting get registered for
the free webinars George what do they
get if they go to yours well we give
away stuff and uh that's I like to bribe
people with that so we'll give away some
stuff we have a I kill you really are
you just making a joke no we really do
we've given away uh prods I already give
away your services I know we gave away
some books and products and things like
that for those that are brave enough to
ask a question in front of you know
3,000 virtual people CU that's there is
a cap even though it's digital they cap
the room size so you got to make sure
you sign up we'll also send you a replay
if you miss it a lot of people say hey I
can't make that time sign up anyways you
can go back and watch the whole thing
there you go and free stuff for the
people that do attend and ask a question
and you bribe people for their
involvement you got but people do get
really Interactive heard the story yeah
we've had great feedback just showing
them we don't have time on the air to
show you how it all works but that
webinar is where we do it Olivia is in
Madison Wisconsin hi Olivia welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi George thank you for
taking my call sure what's up um so my
question is about student loans um I
currently have um a um I have around
three uh let's see
105,000 in student loans um
and it's broken up between um a private
uh University Foundation loan and then
Federal loans um and my question is um
the the Federal Loan is broken up into
smaller loans yes um some of them are
subsidized some are unsubsidized yes and
so my question is how do I prioritize
that do I or do I just pay the private
and then the
Federal
I'll tell you how I did it 10 years ago
I laid them all out from smallest
balance to largest balance that's called
the debt snowball method and I ignore
the interest rates just black them out
if you have to because it gets real
confusing and overwhelming and all you
do is you focus on that smallest balance
first my guess is it's one of those
little Federal
loans yes what's the smallest balance
you
got um I believe the smallest one is
about five or 6,000 of one of the the
Federal loans yeah what do you
make um my husband and I make um about
115 great so how quick are you gonna pay
that five
off oh we can pay the five off in um
probably couple months Max yeah or more
I was thinking two paychecks yeah okay
quick quick how yeah all of these um
Federal loans are under one service you
need to call them you need to pay the
minimums and then call them and get them
on the phone which is a pain in the butt
cuz they're incompetent but call them
and get them on the phone and demand
that the money you transfer right then
goes on that loan because if you mail it
to them or you make it one check for all
the minimums and that they will screw it
up and spread it across all of them
because they're
incompetent okay up until now we've just
been paying um across all across all of
them yeah and nothing happens yeah and
you don't see any movement but I want
that little one knocked out cuz when
that little one's knocked out your
payment
changes okay
and drops down and then more and more
and more the debt snowball rolls but if
you don't knock out the little one then
the Deb snowball doesn't roll meaning
every time you pay off want something
that has a payment with the debt
snowball that old payment now gives you
extra money to throw on the next one but
if the old payment is zero then it
doesn't give you any extra money to
throw on the next one so you got to call
them in each stinking month make sure
they're doing the right one the right
one the right one when you're on one of
the little small federals
yeah and you can also see online it may
break them out you may be able to apply
that to the principle but I'm not sure
if these websites if you can be if you
can make sure on the website you could
try it one month and see if it drops the
principal on that singular debt rather
than spread across all of them but I got
to tell you there it's the worst it's
the federal government I mean user
experience the incompetence of the IRS
the incompetence of the federal
government shows up here like you never
believe these people's parents are
cousins it's just awful they're just
horrible and so uh it's a it's a
disaster the whole student loan debacle
is a disaster So the faster you get it
in the rearview mirror the better your
life is going to be good question thanks
for joining us Miguel is in San Antonio
hi Miguel welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
Dave and George how youall doing better
than we deserve what's up that's right
um so I'm 22 years old U I have a car
payment at sitting at 10 ,000 left to be
paid off that's the only debt I have um
originally the car started at 18,000 I
had it for two years and so I've been
trying to pay down much ahead of time
just so I can get that completely
finished out um and I do have the money
to pay it off right now I could pay it
off today but that is pretty much
everything that I have so you owe you
owe how much
today uh today it's it's just under
10,000 it's at 9,000 okay and how much
money do you have
um I have 12,000 right now do so I would
still have I make around 40,000 a year
now good and what other debt do you have
other than the stupid
car I don't have any other debt good pay
it off today man it leaves you with what
three grand and no car payment yeah and
and and that doesn't include my um
emergency fund I still have an emergency
F of a thousand okay no no no you're
starter emergency fund you're starter so
so now you got three you got three grand
four grand yeah and now you your next
goal is to build that four grand up to
three to six months of expenses which in
your case is probably about a $10,000
emergency
fund okay and without a car payment
you'll get there even faster
yeah yeah it's so with that yes that I
should pay it off um one more thing I'd
like to add on to the story now is that
I am engaged congratulations have a
wedding when when's the
wedding uh we just signed the contract
for two years ex almost exactly two
years so two years long ways away man
why two
years um my my fiance is still going
through graduate school and I actually
work at a university so she's going to
be able to get graduate school paid for
with uh my benefit there not if you're
not
married a blessing we are planning to
get married legally first and then so
that she can get that benefit
and then we're going to have a wedding
in the church because we are uh Catholic
and we do want
to get married in the church okay so
what does the Catholic Church charge you
to get
married well we wanted we've been dating
for six years and we wanted to we've had
a lot of different people come to our
lives been a part of our story we wanted
to have something um so we have a budget
of around 20 to
25,000 and and with it being just me
right now so you're talking about
actually getting married when
legally 20 legally would be
um pretty much the beginning of 2024 in
February okay and then then then your
husband and wife the other things you're
just going to have a
party exactly okay and so you're going
to save up for a $20,000 party I don't
give a flip when you have your $20,000
party you can have that whenever you
want you're now husband and wife and you
have a paid for car
Tada it doesn't change anything dude
matter of fact it it actually makes it
more sense for you to pay off the thing
today with that combined income the
$10,000 is not going for the party two
years from now for sure while you have a
stinking car payment you're going to
save up new money to pay for the party
or not this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
yeah
George camel Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Jacob and Taylor are on the
debt-free stage in the lobby of ramsy
solutions how are you he how are you
better than I deserve welcome where do
you guys live so we're from Tulsa
Oklahoma oh fun welcome to Nashville how
much debt did you pay so we paid off
about
182,000 good for you how long did that
take too long but about years okay good
and uh what was your range of income
during that time so we started about
70,000 775 and then up to about 125 cool
what do youall do for a living so I'm a
mechanic at Alexa Steeler in Tulsa mhm
uh after I graduated college I ended up
in the nonprofit field for about seven
and a half years uh but now I'm a
stay-at home dog Mom I have a network
marketing business and I'm a part-time R
staff okay good for you cool all right
what kind of debt was the $182,000
so it was student loan for her and then
and then our mortgage I paid off your
house look at the weird people I love it
so what is this house worth in Tulsa
it's worth about 280 now way to go guys
nice house we're seeing it on YouTube
here nice picture yeah and it's all
yours all ours how old are how old are
you two weirdos so I'm 33 I just turned
32 last week you have a paid for house
yes do you know anyone that's 33 with a
paid for house other than George he was
a huge inspiration for us very very big
so well I'm amazed that this trend keeps
happening I feel like we're seeing it
more and
more late 20s early 30s coming in here
with a paid off house definely yeah
we're it's very exciting do you know I
mean any of your friend group got a paid
for house I don't think so not that I
know of yeah they'd be talking about it
if they did yeah that's true very true
they'd be here too where did this idea
even come from how did you guys get
started on this Ramy way eight years ago
yeah yeah good question uh so right
after I graduated college is when we got
married and we actually got Financial
Peace University membership as a wedding
gift and so I'd love to give a shout out
to Tracy a family friend who gifted that
to us and that changed everything for
our family so we took it about 3 months
after we got married and I remember
sitting there the second or third week
and and I was like we have to teach this
like we people need to know about this
and so we went through the class and um
we kind of did things a little a little
out of order we actually like bought our
home home during the class but turns out
we did it right we put 20% down it's a
15year loan all of that so all of that
was right but then we um you know
ventured on the the student loan and we
got that done it was 38,000 and we got
that done in 22 months good so we
knocked that out pretty quickly and so
um right after that class was over we
started teaching um so we've coordinated
uh nearly 15 classes
now thank you we love it absolutely love
it super coordinators you got the stuff
at that point the whole class is looking
at you have you led one since paying off
the house um we had one this summer so
we got to celebrate with them and then
we'll have another one in January so
really kept us accountable you know
working with each of the classes and and
sharing our story and all of that so
it's like your personal trainer having a
six-pack you're like this is a good sign
I'm in the right place when I'm in your
class way to go yes we're excited so we
um in a lot of ways I guess a huge part
of our story is um you know we've had
emergencies come up just like anybody
else um we've replaced our AC unit had a
four night Hospital stay and we also
Jacob is working on his Bachelor and so
we're cash flowing that and so that's
part of the reason why maybe it's taken
a little bit longer and what are you
studying Jacob uh mechanical engineering
oh very good okay how much longer do you
have uh about a year oh wow good for you
that's going to be a great breakthrough
for you yeah but it's been a been an
almost 5year process so but all part
time yeah exactly so and as Newly Weds
we've we've done a lot of traveling um
we've done a couple of international
trips we've been all over the United
States but all with cash all without
credit cards um and so that certainly
has you know extended our um you know
our our deadline I guess but the goal
was always to pay off for home seven
years early yeah um and that's exactly
what we did so go we did it's been
really exciting really once you're out
of baby steps 2 and three travel is
allowed it just slows down you it slows
down how much you put on baby step 6 or
buying a car is allowed or going to
school is allowed it just slows down how
much you put on baby step 6 but you
still did all of that and did the house
in seven years yes yeah pry Co yeah we
sure did it's been been fun it's been
living proof this stuff still works yes
exactly every day yeah and in a lot of
ways too um Jacob and I are both natural
givers um and so outside of our mortgage
our giving category in our budget was
actually one of the largest and so we
are kind of practicing baby step 7even
even kind of before we got there so you
know the travel and and the the giving
part of that you know we give to things
that we're passionate about we just
couldn't wait to do that so amen good
for you yeah good for you okay now how's
it feel when you walk through the
backyard and you don't have any
payments feels nice it really does I
mean you don't we don't necessarily like
worried if that payment was going to be
there the first of the month but it's
nice not having to like even having to
worry about that if y'all walked back in
the backyard and stood and looked at the
house went that's ours mhm we have
actually yes front back walk through the
grass Barefoot yeah pictures neighbors
are going what are they doing over
exactly yes they do a lot of celebrating
over there I don't know that's good good
for you what do you tell people on your
class the secret to getting out of dead
is oh man number one on my list is
tithing that's been just the Forefront
of our mind and why do you think that is
man when you live life like this you
know it it's just better than open
yes yeah it's just better than you can
than you can dream or imagine and so uh
blessings have come from that and and
certainly you know since we have led 15
Financial Peace University classes we
watch the videos 15 times and so um you
know just keeping up with that and and
having a group to walk through that with
has been a really crucial part so yeah
the accountability and the
open-handedness yeah what about you
Jacob I think it's a lot of it is not
living above your means I mean that
we've you know not been in any kind of
dire straight situation but we've also
not like saying oh I need to go into
debt for to do this or I need to put
this money towards the trip and not pay
off what we need to pay off so I think
it's it's knowing what you need as
opposed to just what you want yeah it's
intentionality right yeah yeah way to go
guys I'm so proud of you thank you who
was uh who was cheering you on everybody
everybody um lot of a lot of my parents
instilled a lot of this into into me
from the go so they've always been kind
of that driving force for for me
especially not before we got married and
then since since we've been married
they've been you know a constant
cheerleading team um so and then her
grandma and then our our friends you
know who who know that we're on this
journey or were on this journey you know
they've always been super supportive and
our church family our community group
you know we we've we're surrounded by a
huge support team wow that's awesome
that makes a big difference yeah and you
guys are in your early 30s you got no
payments give me something you're
excited to do in the give save spend
category with no payments now yeah for
sure yeah I mean making our our giving
budget a little bit larger now uh we're
updating our home so like you know
updating the outdoor space and replacing
Windows things like that adulting
adulting exactly yeah so that's any big
trips now you're like this is the big
debt-free
trip yeah actually next May we're going
to go to Italy so we actually uh at a
fundraising Gala prior to co mhm we uh
won the won a trip through a silent
auction and Co kind of ruined that a
little bit um couldn't go well now we
are 3 years on from it we're actually
going to get to go on it and even in a
better Financial place than we were then
to go so that's that we're going to kind
of use that as our celebratory yeah God
that's awesome that's a good trip well
done y'all that's fun yes well
congratulations we're very proud of you
we've got the living give bundle for you
cuz you've been doing a lot of both
living and giving so uh baby steps
Millionaire's book you'll be there very
soon if you're not already I didn't ask
how much you have in retirement how much
do you have in retirement we probably
have I'm think we have probably about
100 Grand now with ir you said the house
is worth 300 close to it yeah so you're
about 400 of the million almost on your
you're on your way to Baby Steps
millionaire good way yeah we got that
book for you that's your next step and
next stop and Total Money Makeover
booked maybe to give to one of your
class members and a Financial Peace
University membership if you find
somebody that can't go will assist you
in your giving uh your generosity plunge
that you're taking that's awesome so
congratulations you guys thank you all
right Jacob and Taylor Tulsa Oklahoma
182,000 paid off house and everything
count it down let's hear a debt-free
Scream 3 2 1 we're dead
[Applause]
free wow excellent excellent
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
shot
our scripture of the day James 1 2 and
three consider it pure joy my brothers
and sisters whenever you face Trials of
many kinds because you you know that the
testing of your faith produces
perseverance Franken Roosevelt said when
you're at the end of your rope tie a
knot and hold on Amen Kristen is with us
in Madison Wisconsin hi Kristen welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave hi George thank you so much
for taking my call sure what's
up um so my husband and I were newly
married uh we just finished baby step
one this month uh we have 45,000
in Consumer Debt in baby step 2 and as
we're laying them out smallest to
largest we also have some other pretty
big expenses that aren't necessarily
debt and we're just having a hard time
figuring out where they should fall in
our snowball what are they we have um so
we have two vehicles one of them we own
outright one of them we have a loan for
$6,200 and the one that we have a loan
on is broken down um the rear
differential is completely seized up
it's not drivable it's going to be about
a $2,000 fix we're hoping to eventually
fix it and then sell it to get rid of it
um also we bought a house at the
beginning of this year and two weeks
after we closed on our house the pipes
in the bathroom burst and so that is
currently completely gutted we don't
have a shower uh sink
um or just in that bathroom at all uh
that's the only bathroom we have in our
house so we've been showering at our
mother-in-law's house um we've been
going over there to do that for how long
and then um for about six months seven
months yeah she was two blocks away
which is great she's super close pretty
big there's nothing great about this
this sucks oh my gosh what a mess and we
Insurance wouldn't cover it um well
that's the other part I lost my job
recently So currently my husband is
working y' need to write a country song
an hour we showered my mother-in-laws
and I lost my job yeah
it's there's a lot wow so what's he
making he's making $18 an hour right now
doing
what uh he's a machine operator what
were you
making I was making uh 60k I was a
restaurant manager why'd you lose your
job um I was working in a restaurant um
I loved my job the hours were not great
I was working 60 to 70 hours a week
salary so I took different position in
the same it was another restaurant
manager position and I moved over to
that it was going to be 45 hours a week
um and that would salary also so that
would allow me a little more time um but
uh a couple weeks into that they decided
that I was not a good fit um and they
let me go when was
that that was uh that was in June why
haven't you worked since
June well that's the other thing my
husband
um
he uh had his driver's license suspended
and the car broke down um so we were
able why did he have his driver's
license suspended I can't believe
this it's been suspended for um for
quite a while he had to wait a couple
years um there was a period of time DUI
for the points yeah and then for the
points to fall off and so he can he's
eligible to get it reinstated now but it
is it's about $800 to pay all the fees
and for everything and then our
insurance would go up okay so your
excuse is you're a full-time driver for
$18 an hour guy I'm calling bull
crap that was a dumb idea you make more
than he
makes yeah and so we were able to share
um we were working in the same town we
were driving yeah back when but now with
him being yeah yeah but now with you not
having a job you used driving him as
excuse to not get a job so get another
job girl couldn't you drop him and then
go work and then pick him up or he gets
a ride there's a lot what you did
before yeah so we were um I can I'm
looking at getting I've been doing um
applying for jobs there were a couple I
got to the second interview um
restaurant manager positions and um you
know they ended up really not going
anywhere but now what I'm looking at is
um what would be wrong with Mike working
60 hours a week
now what was wrong with it then you were
broke yeah
um it was mostly the schedule and
driving back and forth and not being
available to pick him up because I had
to stay late to solve a problem at work
and um so you lost $60,000 cuz he didn't
buy an
Uber yeah you need you got
you guys need to both be committed to 60
to 80 hours a week making $20 an hour
and you will solve a lot of these
problems you have in a heartbeat instead
you're living in a house that's not even
habitable because you don't even have a
toilet or a
shower and you haven't worked since June
you guys have got to go create some
money girl you went from 100K down to 36
and you got 45 in debt so if we get you
back to work problem your income the the
fact you just don't make any money is
your problem and you don't work much
yeah you both need he needs a new job he
needs a new job making 25 an hour and
two extra jobs making 20 an hour and you
need the 60 70 80 hour week 60 to
880,000 to be the restaurant manager job
and buy them an Uber if you're stuck at
work I mean can you wait tables in the
meantime
yes um so that's what our next plan was
I can pay $125 to reinstate my CNA I
have to go take the the test but then I
would be able to get my CNA license back
and that's I'm sorry what is CNA what is
a CNA license CER certified nurse
assistant and what would that
pay uh $25 an
hour 20 why would you want to do that
when you can make 60 as broke as you are
why don't you go get you some
money I I've been applying for restaur
manager positions I had two where I went
to the second interview second interview
uh process um I've applied for for more
than those but those are the ones where
I was um interviewed and you guys need
to sit down you guys need to sit down
and figure out the way on the short term
not what your dream is but the thing you
can do that is moral and legal that
allows you all to work the most hours
and make the most money for about 2
years so you can get your shower fixed
and get your debt paid off
but you're not going to do it with all
these theories and all these limitations
and you're finding all kinds of reasons
to not do this stuff um really honestly
50 Grand solves your whole
life 50,000 bucks you could have made
that since June if he was working
overtime and you were still working and
so you really have an
income your perception of work and your
perception of income on a temporary
basis needs to change that is your issue
because you guys need to BU you know $18
and I mean in a in a world where most
people are making 25 to 30 okay uh and
no you don't go get a CNA to make $25 an
hour when you have the income potential
of 60 to 80,000 at a restaurant and in
the meantime until you land that you go
get six jobs and you guys work your tail
ends off I'm fixing my freaking toilet
and my shower this is crazy y'all go
make some money girl we want you to win
but you you you guys spend a lot of your
mental the in talking to you there's a
lot of mental gymnastics on how why we
can't create an income there was a lot
of them I mean you're like a a world
class gymnast well I know life has
happened to you I know it has but it's
got stuck in your head and you got this
Loop going and I'm trying to force you
even if you get mad at me I'm doing that
cuz I love you I'm trying to force you
to rethink your view on work well every
question that was well there's a story
behind I know but we at some point we
just have to put it down and do it
anyways and go to work anyways do the
job we don't want to do anyways yeah
exactly yeah you your $50,000 changes
your whole life you could go make 50 to
100,000 more than you made in the last
12 months in the next 12 months between
the two of you changing in your view on
work that's how that's how fast your
life can turn around and and the
desperation that you feel every day when
you go to your mother-in-laws to take a
shower will go
away that puts us hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
do you love a good dayve rant want to
see the latest Ramsey Show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsey Show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsey Show Channel
on
[Music]
YouTube